[Music]
wow you guys wow I just watched the
light no Fire trailer this was a new
game that was announced at the game
awards from the developers behind no
man's Sky now I have never played no
man's sky but if you followed the
development of that game this was a game
that was known for promising a lot and
it launched it didn't really deliver on
that but over time through updates free
updates I've heard that it's actually a
pretty good game now so this trailer I
don't know that anyone knew about it
going into the game awards I certainly
hadn't heard about it but now it seems
like we're going to get Hello Games take
on a fantasy world now this was only a
2-minute trailer and I had to slow it
down to about 25x speed I watch the
whole thing at25 speed because there are
a number of moments in the trailer where
they throw these quick scenes on and
they kind of pop up in Rapid succession
you miss what's happening there unless
you slow it down so we're going to watch
this trailer together now guys and I'm
going to point out I've got a full page
of notes here in front of me we're going
to take a look at all of this because
man I'm trying not to let the hype get
too high we still don't know release
date or anything like that but this game
is looking very very impressive all
right guys we got the headphones on
we've got this in the maximum quality
possible and before we even hit play on
this you can see that there are four
different styles of characters here you
have one with kind of long white hair
pulled back you've got one with looks
like brown hair and then this kind of
horned I don't know if it's a mask or if
it's just a helmet then we have more of
a ranger type here with a hood three of
them you can see this one here here and
here they all have bow and arrows this
guy it looks like maybe
potentially is that two swords there is
that just part of the backpack and then
over here we have a rabbit character and
then just this view I mean I could have
picked just about any shot from this
trailer for the thumbnail because that's
how good this game looks a multiplayer
Earth so it is going to be multiplayer
and then you see right here a procedural
Earth so my hope with this is that
they're taking everything they learned
from No Man's sky and trying to
procedurally generate an entire galaxy
and they're taking the positives that
they learned what they did well from
that and they're putting them into this
game which is just one planet I say just
one planet because from everything I've
read and heard they're trying to make it
to scale of like our actual Earth which
is insane now this part's really
interesting right here you might think
oh we just have a couple of skeleton
enemies walking forward here but look at
this we've got two skeleton kids here so
are we going to be seeing skeletons with
families I mean is the skeleton even the
bad guy here is he just trying to raise
his two kids in peace I have so many
questions it looks like they're making
their way up here to this kind of ruined
area also this sort of yellowish smoke
over here on the left I don't know if
that's some kind of poisonous gas or
something but that definitely caught my
eye as
well all right and then at this shot
right here I mean I don't even know what
to call this a death star that's that
was my first thought even though this is
more of a fantasy Earth this is supposed
to be
ancient some ancient looking structure
here and then this guy over here on the
left you can see he has kind of this
glowing blue sword a bulkier character
this time and then don't miss this guy
over here we've got a short one here and
then we have sort of these hooded items
again you've got like the antlers here
and then this one with the horns so it
seems like there's going to be so much
variety not only in the world around us
but the characters that you can actually
play as and because it's
multiplayer it's the possibilities man
again I'm trying to keep my hype in
check but this is a game that I could
see myself spending a lot of time
in okay then we get the underwater all
footage ingame multiplayer now notice in
the bottom left corner over there that
little indicator I don't know what
everything means yet but I'm pretty sure
we've got a temperature gauge and right
there you see when they shifted from
water to land this right here this
little icon here here we'll go back just
so you can see it here so right here it
has kind of like this fish icon and then
the moment they pop up out of the water
it switches over to this Leaf icon so
I'm pretty sure that's just an
indication of the different biome that
you're in and then right here here this
little gauge it's hard for me to get it
just right there but the the little
circular part of the gauge I'm pretty
sure that that has something to do with
temperature because you see right here
there's not as much of it there's not
much orange there and then watch as soon
as we pop up out of the water
here you're going to see it jump up
instantly okay right that shot right
there that is where the0 25x speed
really comes in handy we have to slow it
down we have to watch this together
because there is so much going on in
just those few shots that kind of pop up
in Rapid succession there so first of
all over here on the right we have a
dragon and then we have a big one that's
going to fly right overhead but while
you're distracted by the dragon don't
miss look at this right in here we have
some sort of creature that just goes
darting by I I don't even know what to
call this creature maybe it exists in
our real world maybe it doesn't and I've
just never seen it or I'm not familiar
with it but we see one of these little
guys go darting across here and then
we're about to get to the moment when
they sort of flash between three to four
scenes very quickly right there there is
the first one so we have just this
floating cube here in the air and then
this might be the part that gets me the
most excited about this trailer I've
always loved using magic in games
surprise surprise right this character
right here he's got the hood he's got
the the cape and everything he's holding
the staff and we can see this kind of
Crystal which looks very similar to that
Crystal from before that we saw on the
back of the guy it was like a sword this
one we can see right here in the staff
so you you already know we're going to
be able to cast magic with that and this
one looks just otherworldly right here
this looks like it is from a completely
different planet but we know it's all
taking place on the same Planet here and
then we also have this little flag right
here so I wonder if that could be an
indication of once you discover a
territory you can like put the flag down
and then maybe fast travel then the very
next shot we get this one right here
gliders confirmed so in this trailer we
see multiple types of ridable mounts we
see these gliders we see underwater and
then we see all these different items
that our character is going to be able
to carry like the bow and arrow like the
sword like the staff this right here man
it almost seems like they're taking
breath of the wild meets Skyrim meets no
man's Sky which oh my goodness dude sign
me up for that and we're only 30 seconds
in man we are only 30 seconds into this
trailer and then this next shot right
here man another one of my favorite ones
in the entire trailer mainly because it
shows off just the sheer variety of
potential things that we could encounter
in this world while the the beautiful
shots of the The Greenery and the water
and the clouds all look great this does
a great job of showing you the other
side of that I mean this this looks
bleak right here we've got the rain
coming down I'm not sure if that's
flashing from a storm maybe lightning
and then just the the vegetation here
everything looks dead and then we have
these birds just massive birds that are
mountable so it's one thing to have
dragons that are mountable in a game
which is a very you know typical thing
we've seen that before in Min games but
here we're going to be able to mount
these birds that are larger than our
character and then over here look at
this guy I mean I assume that this is
also a type of character that we'll be
able to choose it's like how many
different races how many different types
of creatures are going to be playable in
this game and then moving on here again
I told you guys you could literally
freeze it at just about any frame of
this trailer and get something
absolutely gorgeous in this shot here
we've got the character right here
running and then we also have a smaller
character possibly a dwarf of some kind
over here on the right this shot right
here showing us a little little bit
about the building in the game I'm not
sure what's going on with this guy up
here is he just floating in midair right
there let's take a oh wait he just he
jumped off I watched the at 025x speed
and completely missed that there he is
right there and then he just he just
goes and jumps off with his glider oh
man that's so good but this shot right
here we can see this guy kind of
chopping down the tree here another look
at the completely different races I mean
we're going to have so many different
races it seems like in this game that
are human
I guess to a degree he's carrying the
wood here then we've got some building
going on right here and right here I
mean does that say home you guys think
that says
home it does right there but then as we
get a little bit closer see if we can
freeze it again uh h m maybe that's an e
I'm not
sure you can see that building right
there and then look another bird
completely different style of bird so
this one very different than the one we
just saw in the previous shot
all right there we go with another uh
several different scenes back to back to
back rapid succession let's back up and
watch those another huge Dragon he's got
the giant Barbed tail right here you can
see a little boat here in the distance
and then another one here and then
another one very very close to us take
another look at this character right
here is that a skunk a raccoon just the
sheer amount of types of different
characters that we're going to be able
to play as is staggering I mean even
from this trailer again I I'm trying to
hold the hype in we've seen this before
with Hello Games you know they make big
promises but fingers crossed man fingers
cross that they've learned oh and I
didn't see even me going back now and
watching I'm catching more things I
didn't notice we got two more ships over
here this character right here again you
see a lot of characters walking around
with this pack so I assume that's going
to be a key part of the game is this
pack that we carry around we can see
these Ranger type characters so we've
got the little hood here bow and arrow
and it seems that they are hunting these
bore like uh animals down here but we
also in addition to these two up here
you've got the two right here we've got
one here so it looks like they're all
kind of working together to hunt these
boar all right this next shot we have
this giant craike enemy can see kind of
these reddish pink eyes here the Flaming
sword don't miss the Flaming sword now
question is is that just the typee of
sword that is or is this some sort of
buff that we put on the sword and so
it's temporarily lit on fire I have so
many questions also don't miss the
smaller crab likee enemies that we have
walking around here as well this one
that this shot right here it just
happens so quickly so if you don't slow
it down you'll totally miss it again
we're getting a look at the different
types of mounts here so I'm just going
to call this one a dragon that looks
most like a dragon to be then we have
the bird and this one right here in the
middle let's let it play for a little
bit here so kind of just a different
style of dragon it seems like to me now
when we hop on I want you to look in the
bottom right corner see how that bow and
arrow shows up so my guess is that means
we're going to be able to do aerial
combat I can't think of any other reason
that that would be displayed
there now these shots that we see in
Rapid succession here aren't quite as
detailed as some of the other ones but I
do think they show you a good look at
the sheer variet iy I've said sheer
variety a lot in this but I just keep
coming back to that right here though
you do get a look at a different style
of dragon we also have the weather
effects going on right here we get a
look at the bird again we can see the
difference in our character looks like
they're dressed more for a winter
environment something much colder but
look at that man just look at that shot
we have all this green area here and
then at the tip top of this mountain
you've got the snowcapped area right
there and I mean from Hello Games you
know you're going to be able to go and
explore that you know you're going to be
able to land this anywhere you want and
just oh man I seriously cannot wait to
explore this then you can see right here
they have like this uh kind of brazer
that's been lit there some type of
Beacon and unfortunately it cuts away
before we can get a closer look at this
little area right here I mean this is
kind of a smaller Outpost I don't know
maybe it's some kind of checkpoint you
can see the little orb up here that's
glowing green it almost looks too small
for our Dragon to even land there but
maybe it's kind of that depth perception
thing maybe as we get closer it's a
little bit larger maybe this is kind of
a landing area over here that
immediately cuts into this shot right
here where we can get a look again at
the rain and this is a nighttime
environment you've got the torch here
notice the icon over in the bottom right
changes I guess this is whatever you
have kind of equipped in your primary
hand at the time so earlier when we were
flying on the dragon you saw thought was
the bow and arrow here we can see that
it's the torch and I love this guy over
here he's just standing by the fire
standing by the fire holding out his
hands to get
warm and then right here look at this
large structure it lights up and then
right in here you can definitely see
that this looks to be the direction that
they're going so I don't know if this is
some sort of Base that they've already
set up or if this is something that
they're getting ready to go and explore
some type of dungeon but I am certainly
interested in whatever they're about to
take on there and look at this did you
miss the eyes here don't miss the eyes
they look like eyes to me anyway you've
got a little set right here a set right
here and a set right here right here
right here I don't know if you guys spot
any others that I miss let me know in
the comments below but looks like some
sort of shadow creature just lurking
there and watching us as we approach
this structure oh yeah oh yeah right
before it cuts away definitely some sort
of creepy shadow creature almost looks
like an octopus you can see the
tentacles kind of moving here watch when
we let it
play oh that's creepy
man now we've talked a lot about the
variety of our character uh and also you
got to talk about the variety of the
mounts as well I mean we we've seen
birds we've seen dragons now we've seen
what do we have here I don't know I
don't I don't even know some type of
horse goat creature and even even among
these creatures you can see that they
have different colorations on them
different
patterns now I think this next scene has
to be some sort of story moment here you
can see that our rabbit character here
now has this Shield that matches the
emblems that are up here on this uh
adorning the sides of this doorway here
and then these rabbits are all kind of
bowing down to us so I'm not sure if
they're kind of wishing us good luck or
if we've already accomplished something
and now we're on our way out but right
before this shot Cuts away let's play it
a little bit here you can see there's
another character here now I wondered if
this is some type of blacksmith it looks
like a really large ogre troll type
character you can see there are some
weapons here and then he's got this
little bench here and then behind him
there is a doorway which is open so
possibly that's his area where he makes
uh weapons and stuff for us but then as
we approach you can see that he he looks
like he's getting ready to talk to us
right there just before it cuts away and
then just before the trailer ends they
give us one final look riding a dragon
soaring across this just gorgeous area
you see that mysterious Stone structure
off in the
distance man I know that trailers are
designed to get you
hyped what could I say it it worked for
me